Pamela add line is coming in welcome
this is like a a family reunion hello do
you know Phil Salomon okay like most
women are you nervous about I was crazy
before so this is awesome for me were
you are you are you a little OCD by the
hands I didn't know that oh yeah huge we
always hugged when I would see you so it
wasn't that yeah just I don't I don't
generally like touch anything
Wow look at your moving the mic with
your wrist now I saw you yeah I saw you
on Twitter you had that like coronavirus
mask on to travel and I thought it was
just like I'm just kidding around
I know but not so much no I have this
thing called thieves spray which is like
cinnamon and cloves and so I sprayed the
thieves in the mask and I but I don't
think any of it works listen just keep
your hands clean don't touch your eyes
don't touch your nose don't run your
mouth how long have you been like that
with the hands I generally don't like
touching I'll give you a hug but I don't
want it I don't want to feel your hand
mm-hmm
you know I mean no offense but it's like
and usually it's Phil it's not you it's
but you know when I meet like kids who
are like my daughter's age like the boys
in their 20s and whatever and they put
their hands out I'm like I'm good bro
you say no oh all the time you hugged
him at least yeah I'll give somebody a
hug I'll hug when did you get to that
place in your life where you have to
make the decision like what is more
difficult for me the awkwardness of
saying no I'm not going to shake your
hand or the the inner turmoil of I'm
touching your hand no what I did a show
with Howie Mandel years ago I played his
like brother on this show called what
was the animated show that he did Bobby
Bobby's world yes oh I didn't know you
were on Bobby's world yeah and he and he
lovely but he was the first person that
I ever saw who would refuse to shake
hands and he would give you the elbow
not even the fist just like the yellow
bearskin do you think that maybe that
might mean that you have a problem if
you're going to Howie Mandel to
normalize your German behavior because
how it was like the thing that cracked
my head open like oh you're allowed to
do this I don't really get bothered by
shaking hands but with the hugging when
somebody's like hair touches you or when
you feel somebody's breath or something
like that and you go this is I have a
really disgusting story go ahead I was
at the airport every woman who dates me
says I was at the airport in a coffee
being waiting to get a coffee and I had
you know my hair was all nice and
freshly blown dry and I was getting on a
plane got my coffee and somebody was
behind me and they were just like right
up on me and they were coughing and I
was like Oh God then they didn't stop
and so I finally got away from them sat
down in my seat put my hand on my hair
and I felt a wad and I just kind of I
just stopped and I went to the bathroom
and I wash my hair in the sink because I
knew that the person behind me had
hocked a like a huge waster that's awful
into my [ __ ] so he washed your hair with
him you think so because the person
behind me
and I just kind of stood up and I just
went in the sink and you walk out of the
plain bathroom that's it and you have
like fresh washed sink hair and he's
like what was she doing but that's
disgusting for anybody's gusting you're
really upsetting oh and the rest of your
fly if I thought of it oh no I just I
was out of my mind
yeah I feel like I'd want to cut the
hair yes right hotel did you shower
so much yes so nasty sorry yeah I mean
there's some stories that even I'm not a
germaphobe but that would disgust me
somebody's coughing or hacking yeah yeah
coughing was bad enough but that actual
material was left like mmm I had to like
yeah I don't know if that does the guy
tell ya you know like if it go if I
coughed in no way never say anything
wait till they're on the plane let them
find no walk away never happened now
know that if that happened to you that's
your embarrassment I'm not gonna
acknowledge it it's not my embarrassment